bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto e
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
e oggi siamo suite farc in my eyes tra
che una casa o map di amnesia dagli
stessi creatori di the small hors della
quale sono arrivato l'episodio due
radiatori a ci sarebbe anche l'episodio
tre soltanto che non l'ho fatto perché
non mi sembra divertente come quelli
precedenti fatemi sapere se invece mi
sto sbagliando e volete che lo faccia
perché io ho saltato perché non mi
sembrava tanto divertente ma invece
magari mi sbaglio non lo so fatemelo
sapere
io direi di andare avanti tanto questa
non c'entra nulla con the small o
un'altra sempre non senza direi di
iniziare prima di staccarci dal co
sudando non ma utilizzate brand list e
gli affanni e custom story si la più
bella e la più amichevole custom story
enjoy
grazie mille abbiamo voglia di iniziare
magari invece di stampi a legge non lo
fa o c'è ragazzi dovremmo essere fino
alle 2 ore ce l'abbiamo fatta siamo
risvegliati in una casa fantastica
celebra raga all'aran per chi non
conoscesse the small hors la mappa di
amnesia più seria che abbiano mai fatto
quindi aspettatevi qualsiasi cosa perché
non ai dari che cos'è sta roba per che
luccica e lo posso prendere cos'è cos'è
sta roba non lo so non leggo perché non
c'ho voglia andiamo avanti così ma è
troppo fighi un miglior based devo
dargli il mio pranzo migliore va bene
allora devono cucinare presumo era cos'è
sta roba
raga io io ho visto gioco non capì cos'è
cos'è sta roba
vabbè io non devo farmi lo sapete chi
stava era questo questo ragno pranzo
migliore fatemi capire
[Musica]
ragazzi e mi sa che lo drogato non so
che cosa gli ho dato ma è di sicuro è la
peggio della marijuana vabbè comunque
ragazzi non va bene ok questo non me
l'aspettavo però perfetto
sì va bene ho capito non posso entrare
come cup cosa dovrei fare qui c'è un
amico che ha fame se qua dentro
ok mi serve una chiave di amnesia
perfetta non ho capito cos'è ma non
importa
devo trovare una chiave in giro da
qualche parte non so dove va bene che
cos'è quel c'è una sci una scimmia c'è
una scimmia nella vasca da bagno
giustamente che cazzo me ne fate
prenditi anche la smangiati anche la
city si è mangiata la cina ragazza sta
roba i non so che cos'è ma è il
predatore più temibile della terra si
mangia pezzi di meteorite che quello non
so che cos'era e anche le scimmie è una
cosa impressionante cosa devo cos'è
cos'è sta roba da fare perché gestito
fame di sky this is the key to your dog
e i favi desiste ai tour indoor bene
ragazzi è la chiave per la porta perché
se non merda brutto stronzo di un
coccodrillo non puoi ci sono dei top
ragazzi sono i topi mi vogliono stuprare
via aiuto confessa c'è un camion
perfetto c'è un camion entriamo via via
gridiamo non puoi guidare senza le
chiavi della macchina li ha dimenticati
dov'è che cazzo ne so dove sono le
chiavi della macchina io cioè non ho
capito
cioè michele l'armadio datemi la chiave
ho bisogno di guidare cos'è sta roba non
lo so
e cosa c'è qui dentro ragazzi cos'è sta
roba non ho trovato una chiave insolita
di amnesia
ho trovato un cavaliere che prega
perfetto ragazza bene aiuto ha tentato
di aggredirmi maledetto
ok è quello era un cavaliere il
cavaliere stupratore perfetto dare la
chiave
iamm mesi cosa è un accendino devo
usarlo ma chi ha messo un topo cosa ci
fai sulla mia camicia maledetto stronzo
cosa vuoi fare lato a tu l hai trovato
le due chiavi quella era una chiave
della macchina un topo intoppo come
chiave della macchina fatemi capire che
cazzo di sterzo già stamapa voi contate
queste mappe qui di amnesia le sto
facendo per temporeggiare sommesi a2
quindi immaginatevi che cazzo può uscir
fuori quando uscirò fa quando parla mesi
azzurra beh ci siamo
stiamo guidando un camion in amnesia
non so con che criterio ma va bene così
ma vabbè alla ragazzina cos'è sta musica
ti sembra mi sembra la musica dei
pokémon vagamente non lo so ragazzi
ecco cos'è e lo stupratore di prima bene
abbiamo un camion che stiamo andando non
so dove ragazzi e bambini e rendetevi
conto che questo è amnesia cioè commedia
io non voglio più farmi domande quando
gioca
quello cos'è cos'è un autogrill cos'è
era ok ragazzi giugno se ne sta andando
non so dove cioè io sono stato un ora e
mezza ad aspettare che questo cazzo di
camion arrivasse a destinazione
e poi mi cade che cosa vuol dire cos'è
un ragazzo madonna mi ha veramente non
so con che criterio l'hanno chiamato
insorti in my eyes che vuol dire che mi
fa male agli occhi a me fa male allora è
chiesta roba che mi spara
vabbè cos'è ci sono dei lavoratori
benissimo siamo sempre sarnese ragazzi
non dimenticate velo no perché è facile
confondersi va bene lavoro anch'io già
che ci sono va giochiamo qualcosa tipo i
pokémon cos'è un make up sembra un mega
pokédex oddio la nova star di qui
lasciate gioco stronzi di merda fatti
scendere devo salire a quart alloggio ok
perfetto ci siamo ragazzi ci siamo
tranquilli tranquilli come come faccia
dover saltare sopra in tempo tipo così
vai ok ci dovremmo essere belle ragazze
e allora stiamo andando in luoghi
sconosciuti issimi al mondo mi fai
vedere che cosa se no perché mi sembri
un tipo che lavora molto seriamente non
lo so l'idea di andare lì mi ricorda
esserci più sto cos'è quel che è quello
buongiorno una mazza di collocamento di
porta
non prendo ordine a un gruppo che ci hai
capelli davanti agli occhi fatti una
plastica facciale
si no non ho capito un cazzo di quello
che hai detto no
i ragazzi mi sta facendo veramente paura
dice io stanotte mondo
cosa devo fare qui up perfetto da
ragazzi siamo mi spieghi chi sei
mi fai paura devo devo prendere un
pullman ma stai carnefice detti faccio
arriva alcun ceffo nell'iperspazio vabbè
dove siamo ragazzi sesto testo qui fammi
spiegare non voglio spiegazioni sono
incazzato va bene perché c'è uno schermo
li raga io non so che cosa questo devo
fare quasi a prestava aprite maledetti
fate qualcosa di accesso a porta qui
nuova ok entremo di qua bene raga io ho
sempre sognato di andare al cesso col
pedobear va bene è già occupato perché
c'è tende nel buco del gesto
grazie
beh
ragazzi io sto avendo paura
vabbè io devo mi mi dispiace se faccio
scusa tende però a non eden da junior ed
andrew non si capiva bene senti chiunque
tu sia una micciano chicago in testa tu
non mi guardare mentre caso che
maleducazione brutto stronzo
va beh sì ho detto non guardarmi vabbè
io raga non ci riesco io sono troppo
osservato senti junior scusami se ti ho
disturbato va bene così
e tu brutto bastardo vedi di guardarmi
di meno perché non è buona educazione
vabbè se ti draga io esco di qua cosa
devo fare
sai che allora che sto girando a vuoto
lo ha capito che devo fare c'è di tutto
e allora fa se non questa è la porta di
entrata c'è da farci siamo arrivati non
penso che debba fare così sto tornando
indietro forse devo fare così perché
l'unica cosa che non ho ancora fatto
cosa si fa aridaje questo cazzo de canio
e vabbè dai però
[Musica]
ragazzi sul collegato addosso cioè non
pensavo che è successo esploso una mina
bene è il camion è intatto
questi sono i tabù tara che si sono
camion resistenti non come quelli di una
volta
ok si è spento siamo non parte più
perfetto ai ragazzi siamo la batteria
andata siamo ok ci siamo fermati ad uno
shopper haga perché la batteria è andata
minchia bene direi che siamo ne
approfitta per fare acquisti raga prendo
qualcosa allora ragazzi ci siamo
perfetto raga fuori e piena di
stupratori
quindi io direi di rimanere dentro dove
siamo siamo ad uno shop bellissimo
ragazzi questo lo comprò qualsiasi cosa
sia lo compro che ci fa rufy qui perché
maina fin qui dal credito che ai ragazzi
io devo pagare con qualcosa ma non so
cosa da datemi i soldi
datemi speciality robot dalla casa rophé
ti pago col one piece
oddio ragazzi ci sono dei delle teste di
cannes e qui va bene una testa di cane
come pagamento
non lo so ragazzi e fantastico sto
trovando di tutto in sto frigorifero
benissimo io ti spacco una bottiglia in
te non penso che sia servito a qualcosa
non se non è cambiato idea verona verrà
infatti non ha cambiato idea con cosa
vuoi che paghi non ho niente ha forse
trovo qualcosa nell'armadio raga cos'è è
un ragazzo fu sentito questo va bene non
lo so non puoi usare l'oggetto in questo
modo allora non rompere le palle
te lo metto qui non funziona nel culo fa
funzionano lo so vediamo
non funziona neanche lì raga è
complicata la faccia ce sta roba che
però non mi convince
forse documenta cimicata ok direi che ha
funzionato
cos'è ok benissimo bene senti c'e mica
degli spiccioli grassi anch'io sono
molto felice di vederti mi hai dato a
cruz soldi one home nipon dentale al
prefetto un talento onnipotente mai così
tieni grazie mille rose e ha trovato la
benzina per la mia macchina fantastico
hai ricevuto la benzina dato macchina
ora prendere a casa sei ubriaco pensi
sono veramente sono più che ubriaco sono
proprio drogato
se sto giocando a sta roba ma non
importa vabbè aprite che ci sono gli
stupratori fuori ok ragazzi e il camion
ha sfondato la vetrina siamo dei ragazzi
siamo abbiamo parcheggiato penso male i
camion ma non importa va bene così
torniamo a casa che siamo ubriachi ma
forte e non poco
siamo tornati se ragazzi stiamo siamo
tornati a casa
il viaggio mi è piaciuto tantissimo bene
allora ragazzi io mi porto questo come
souvenir e direi di tornare il caso già
che ci siamo è tutto buio è normale io
io io sto male al buy cos'è quella roba
che si muove da che c'è qualcuno di
sistemi maledetto è una festa a sorpresa
non lo sapevo c'è anche gocce breezer
una festa a sorpresa per me addirittura
ma non dovevate cos'è favi gesto anche
di bronzo grazie a questo non lo sapevo
grazie mille e anche koch grazie al
fantastico ragazze
l'aci airbag to and games 6 a beat for
amica paris rega è stato fantastico
veramente vabbè ragaglia tirelli
concludere qui perché sta diventando
assurdo
a parte che mi sta stordendo le orecchie
la musica comunque se volete
vabbè io vado a dormire perfetto così
siamo tutti contenti e mi passa la botta
dato che sono ubriaco evidentemente la
rega ma le musiche visto non possono
fantastica vabbè io io direi di
concludere qui perché sta diventando
strana la colla e ci teniamo a farla
perché la l'ultima degli autori di the
small orso dato che avevano fatto the
small hors fatemi sapere se volete che
io faccio desmo l'orsa ancora il perché
ci sarebbe una terza parte va bene
niente io concludo qui il video perché
direi che può bastare per oggi tenetevi
pronti per domani perché ci sarà il se
quel di una serie epica vabbè io direi
di concludere qui i temi dove piaciuto
come al solito lasciate un commento mi
piace anche alla pagina di facebook e
come in ogni video trovate nella
descrizione sera il sito alcuni siti
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo in un
prossimo vito bene ragazzi